this is a little unusual Andy in this
part of the show is you're aware will
usually have some prepared piece of
comedy always but today unfortunately we
screwed up I forgot it I think it's at
home it's actually on my coffee table I
know right where it is oh no it's like
maddening you can picture it's just
sitting there I know this funny hat I
was gonna wear but anyway it's too late
to go get it now so I thought to pass
the time why don't we have a staring
contest you know the first person to
break their concentration loses so you
can blink right you can blink
you can't break the gaze right you just
got to stare at each other we you know
you did this when you were kid okay well
anyway if I remember correctly Andy we
uh I think we did this one other time as
I as I remember I won yeah you remember
correctly but I think this time I'll do
it I mean it yeah I don't think so
anyway there's only one way to find out
are you ready to do it staring contest
I'm ready you people want to see this
this is never I don't this is very very
unusual you should know if they said no
I'd get on that bike with Farrah and
ride out of town all right here we go Oh
ready okay one two three
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I win you lose
yes thank you thank you very much